shouldn't you be obeying the law that
you enforce and no comment in order to
make money the Tao loves to cite people
for cracked windshields and anything
dangling from the rear-view mirror some
color policing others colored extortion
the Mountain View Colorado cops are on
the lookout for air fresheners fuzzy
dice rosaries even cracked windows
because they're extreme - right
obstructed view citation for you last
year the tiny 12 block town doled out
885 obstructed view citations that's
more than Denver Aurora and Boulder
combined seatbelt violations are another
favorite they just got 1725 of those hey
Lou I'm gonna need a new one of these so
what's the best way to avoid getting
busted just be a Mountain View cop I
noticed that you have the Broncos a
fuzzy dice over the rearview mirror here
isn't that obstructed view sir could be
considered it could be considered no you
shouldn't no comment shouldn't you be
obeying the law that you enforce him no
comment go through the car wash shake
that money's for the source of revenue
for the town the taxes and the Town
Council was told by a consulting group
made up of former police chiefs that the
town should just disband its police
department the local politicians still
support their Road pirates no concerns
in there about the integrity of your
Police Department but come on
no cops have better things to do even
though Mountain View employs nine cops
to patrol just 12 blocks officers from
neighboring towns were reportedly called
in dozens of times last year to assist
Mountain View's finest with crimes like
domestic violence and burglary maybe if
the cops stop Crane on peaceful
motorists they'd have more time to
protect residents from violent thugs and
thieves followed the show and Twitter
submit you nominees for next month and
check out Wendell thing this month's
featured followers this is a big shot
with Twitter in me are you twittering me
jaywalking on my watch